Speaker 1: Let's go next to mark
from Los Angeles. Mark, you're on
the air. Hello, can you help me? Yes, I can.
Speaker 3: Oh, awesome. I can't believe I'm on
the show again. Yay. I I asked before I called
before about Stacey Abrams and the whole thing
happened and I think was Georgia. Hmm. So what
do you think? First of all, I'd like a couple,
maybe two or two questions what have and get
and get in? What do you think's going to happen
with, you know, Biden's like, talking tough,
like he really wants to reform the filibuster
and actually get us, you know, get get the
voting rights bill passed. Do you think
that's going to actually happen, though? Or
is this more talk like a reconciliation bill?
Speaker 1: You know what? I want
to be optimistic about that.
I have a really hard time believing it's going
to happen because reforming the filibuster,
you need all 50 senators, and Joe
Manchin doesn't seem like he's going
to go for it. And neither does Kirsten
cinema. So it's feeling like it's just
talk. I don't know. I want to be proven wrong.
Speaker 3: But yeah, but Joe Manchin kind of said,
like, Oh, he'd be open to to to making it a
talking filibuster buster. But do you think
he's just, you know, pardon my language,
but you think he's just bullshitting the
mostly with the reconciliation bill?
Speaker 1: The most recent thing I
saw from Manchin is he said he'd be
open to making some mutual changes
to the filibuster, which sounds like he's saying
mutual with Republicans. I don't. I don't really
know. I'm just not sure. But listen, if you
if it's just an even money bet, do they change
the filibuster? I feel like they don't.
Speaker 3: Yeah, yeah. I'm feeling, yeah,
I'm just after the afterbirth and reconciliation
bill, I'm just prepping myself for disappointment.
Yeah. Anyway, also, I want to know why do
you think people, I work for a union, OK? And
like literally like like almost 50 percent
of my members are conservative, even though
Republicans and conservatives
were the ones who put forward
right to work laws. And remember when Mitch
McConnell, when they were talking about reforming
the filibuster and Mitch McConnell made
this threat and he may keep threatening
to do two things? One of them was what was the
other one? Oh, in national national voter ID,
which is actually in the the voting rights bill
now. It's just it's more a looser version of
voter ID where you don't have to get some I.D.
that you have to have a bunch of paperwork and
money to get. Yes, and you make national right to
work law. So that's literally him saying a dream,
you know, idea for Republicans. And yet yet,
you know, like there are there are tons of
union members who vote for him. I don't get it.
Speaker 1: It's it is bizarre. And there's this
weird thing about unions where it's not weird, but
it's a notable thing. For a very long time, unions
represented a mostly democratic voting group. They
weren't like progressives in the modern sense,
but they were just kind of like middle class
center left Democrats. And now there's been
a big move away from unions ideologically. And
there's a lot of people who are vocally against
the idea of unions, but they're still part of a
union now. Some of them would say, I have to be
in the job I'm in. I'd rather not. I'd rather not
pay the dues. But you have this weird situation
where you have Republican union members who
love candidates that are against everything
union stand for, but they're still in the union.
And some would say, I have no choice, but there's
definitely a little bit of an inconsistency there.
Speaker 3: Yeah, but it's ridiculous because I'm a
stagehand in our union, we make way more money
than the people who are not union represented.
I mean, we they are there are there are union
members, stagehands with full time jobs who
are making six figures and more. So they
are crazy. I mean, so yeah, there's that.
Let's see. What else do I have to say?
Speaker 1: Well, listen, since we have so
many people waiting, let's let's keep it to those
two questions. I think those were good. Let's go
out on top. You know what I mean?
Speaker 3: OK, let's go on on
a on a positive note. OK, well, I love you,
David. I subscribe. I constantly watch
you and I finally got to call it again.
Speaker 1: Mark, thank you so much. Great to hear
from you. A great point. All right. Very good.